I'm drawing this thing that was really
interesting it was the Twitter
conversation was people go bran got
Tristan Thompson 80 million bran got j.r
60 million bran got a bunch of other
like journeyman players contracts
throughout yeah bran is a better
philanthropist Jordan let Scotty you get
seven years 18 million now a lot goes
into this right a lot goes into this but
a lot was made out of that contract
contract the Scottie Pippen got
important thing to know before you get
crazy upset about Scottie get in seven
years eighteen seven years eighteen
months Jordan signed a rookie contract
for six years mmm okay he was making at
the end of that contract four and a half
million or something like that I can get
the exact statistic it wasn't a lot of
money NBA players weren't making a lot
of money at that time I mean that's
still tons of [ __ ] money all these
people who just got 1200 stimulus check
talking about Scottie only made 18
million it's like you'll never make a
team in your life why you worried about
80-minute but Jordan just a year prior
was only making four million or
something like that four and a half
million Jordan only made crazy money two
years of his career he got the thirty
million dollar contract and then the
thirty six million dollar contract hmm
after that he stops and then he comes
back in place for the Wizards where he
played for like veterans met him it was
like a million or something that so
Scottie wasn't getting that badly ripped
off
Scottie just [ __ ] himself that's what
I Gordon is right I wanted to be mad at
him for Santa Scottie was selfish but
Scottie was selfish self you assigned a
shitty deal that the person [ __ ] you
over told you was a shitty deal I
wouldn't sign this deal you'd want the
money and why not sign it
because you needed the money and that's
fair you needed the money now I don't
know how a family in Arkansas that was
probably raised on under fifty thousand
dollars for the household couldn't
survive on over two million a year I
don't understand like he's like I had to
take care of my family it was i million
for what do you know
I mean it still he has taken himself to
carry yourself for your contact for 10
million dollars you can't take care of a
lot of people yeah but you're a
ballplayer you want to get a nice house
yes all you that's on you that's not oh
no organization so you gotta decide like
don't do the whole I had to take care of
my family [ __ ] you could have taken care
of your family $1,000,000 you give your
family and they are good for the rest of
their life literally for the rest of
life they're fine so I think what we'll
get into other discussions about this
but I think something is really
interesting going on right here is like
they're positioning the bull's
organization especially cross crosses
obviously the villain in the documentary
and unique characters in a documentary
but they're positioning pipin as this
player that was like extremely taken
advantage of right
and he wasn't take advantage of because
he agreed to sign the contract now when
you underperform your contract you don't
give back the money yeah yep I mean I'm
a mix fan I know [ __ ] who
underperform their contract and never
once have they been like you know what
my knee blew out can I give you back two
million a year yeah ever right so if you
silo to [ __ ] give away his trade
closed [ __ ] knee hang up me bragging
wouldn't do it right knee blowout I can
have sympathy for there's a lot of
people were like you know what my
contract here I was in the best shape of
my life and then I just haven't really
committed like this since I signed you
guys should take some money back hmm we
all know contract your players get huge
deals and don't ever they're never that
good again dion Waiters was in great
shape when he knew that he wouldn't he
where I felt so little sympathy for
Scottie Pippen right you signed a deal
that they the Jerry Reinsdorf is no hero
he's no angel yeah if his story which
Scotty doesn't refute at least in the
documentary is I told you not to sign
this deal don't [ __ ] come crying to
me if you sign it that's it you are
warned upfront most that's a wolf in
wolf's clothing wolf in sheep's clothing
I could be mad at you I feel deceived a
wolf who tells me I'm a [ __ ] wolf yo
you sign this contract I'm not letting
you out it yeah this is your [ __ ] and
I will not have sympathy and keep in
mind Scottie Pippen did not come from a
division-one school
I don't what he signed his deal
ninety-one so he wasn't it was a rookie
deal no no I know it was a rookie but
I'm saying it's like he wasn't this he
wasn't Scottie Pippen yet yeah right he
was good but he wasn't Scott he wasn't
one of the 50 greatest players of all
Rana 89 90 they got their first ring I'm
pretty sure so if he's 98 1991 he's off
he's coming off a chip then he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's he's a [ __ ] idea
nothing I thought I thought he signed it
I think he signed it before I thought he
signed it before getting the Rings and
can you look at the ring my bad because
if he signed it before it makes complete
sense is what when he signed the
contract so June is right after winning
a ring either one the ring in every dark
you shouldn't feel bad at all you
shouldn't feel bad at all you're coming
off a championship [ __ ] [ __ ] I need
to take care of my family I'll take
seven years a [ __ ] out of here you're
not another thing you're your first
contract you're taking care of your
family what are you talking about you
your family and what was it Arkansas
your family in Arkansas you can't take
your very favorite what maybe what that
he signed the contract no no he didn't
up in 2000 yeah and he left the team in
97 98 go on everybody's mad at MJ you
made all this money basketball players
didn't make all this money back then you
know why they made all this money I'm
sure MJ he lifted everybody's financial
situation
[Applause]